oh sure okay yeah so when are you going
in a relationship you're in like a
long-distance relationship as well
okay I gotta ask
when you first made Aki right yeah
were you really worried about how she
smelled
like before before
shut the [__] shut the [__] up okay okay
okay like what did you worry be like oh
I hope Sydney doesn't no you're really
Gonna Mail in too much okay okay this is
like did you lick her sweat this is like
pre-mailing talk okay right because I
like I I had a genuine worry I remember
like I had this such a core memory on
the plane yeah like meeting Sydney for
the first time okay obviously we got on
really well I love Sydney I love her
personality but I've never met her in
real life sure but we'd had like video
calls before sure right so but like
here's the thing
there are some senses that you can't get
Beyond like you know on a video call
yeah and I'm like I remember having this
thought being like what if I don't like
the way she smells like like that's
that's a big thing that's a that's a
thing perfect personality perfect uh we
get along conversationally just kind of
smells like [__] you know um
smells like [__] perpetually I I
understand the thing of you gotta like
it whatever it is yeah I mean I mean no
okay I don't call a stink I call it musk
yeah the musk okay like here's the third
strong must I got a [__] incredible
muscle oh yeah
Joey's dying yeah absolutely like here's
the thing right you I to me like you
need to like someone's natural smell
right yes because especially if they're
a partner you're gonna be spending like
so much [__] time with them right
yeah Febreze in it
it's like Sydney hold on
let me let me know
it's gonna work
because here's the thing okay like
okay especially with your life partner
you you to me you have to like pretty
much everything about them you know
um and like smell is uh heavily
important thing especially when it comes
to just like natural senses and stuff
like that you're going to be spending a
lot of time with them especially in like
especially moments and passion yeah of
course that's very very important if you
don't like someone's smell to me that is
like almost a deal breaker like I I have
I there's there have been points when
I've not been attracted to someone
purely because like they have natural
smell that I do not personally like well
considering I've only ever been with one
woman in my life it's car it's kind of
what the [__] what the [__] okay
considering I've only ever been with one
woman in my life that being Archie it's
kind of hard to discern personally yeah
as to the differences in that especially
in like the passion making segment of
things
um but like I've met plenty of women
that smell like [__]
where I'm just like yeah that's kind of
a deal breaker even like
you're not like I'm not you're a lovely
person but I just wish you showered more
you know you would like you've been like
jacking off and then you farted and you
smell it and they just killed
anymore
I mean you even farted as you were like
imagine like yeah about to jack off I'm
gonna do it and then I'm like I don't
want to do it anymore I've heard these
Simon farts before yeah
I'm about to Climax and then somewhere
it smells like [__] and I'm just like oh
that just kind of ruined my day no gonna
I'm a man of commitment no matter what I
follow through so the smell with the
batter of Sydney is what I'm hearing
sorry the smell of Sydney wouldn't have
mattered is what you're saying no I'm
like okay you're a matter of commitment
he would have followed through no okay
so like I remember like I so remember
vividly the first time me Sydney because
I was like [__] no I remember so vividly
because I remember being like I see
Sydney I'm so [__] happy I'm
overwhelmed with positive emotions that
I finally get to meet her in real life
sure and then we hug and then I'm like
I'm so happy and then she smells good
and then and then like literally like
five seconds in I'm just like all right
all right that's [__] all right thank
God thank God that is psychotic if I met
up with a long distance person and I
heard the [__] audible sniff I'd be
like
okay question real talk all right you
guys both had long distance
relationships yeah what was going
through your head on the way to meet
them
um I've never had that so I don't know
what it you know I don't know all I was
thinking of in my head was because you
met at ax I meant yeah weekend of as
that must have been what like a 15-hour
flight was going through your head uh in
my head I was just thinking like God
damn I was just going through my head
okay
no it was only that I refused in my head
I was just like [__] I wish she smells
good
was it like I mean obviously okay in my
in my head legitimately I I think in my
head I was just thinking like I hope she
you know because like I've had before
you know I met Aki like IRL I had a lot
of like online online friends right and
so like I I was already used to kind of
having this like online relationship
with people you know that obviously that
being platonic other than Aki but you
know there are those moments where when
you pursue an online friendship and then
you meet them IRL and they're not quite
the same person yeah so in my head I
think legitimately I was thinking like I
hope she is as [__] cool as she is
online in real life and luckily she came
through and I was like okay thank God
she wasn't like faking that were you
worried about how you were coming off
though as well oh absolutely yeah
absolutely how did you ensure that it
went smoothly oh I activated maximum
risk like I I I try to make sure like
everything I said and did like was like
[__] like yeah
you know what I mean like like you know
just kind of giving off that like cool
demeanor you know and then when we
started like actually talking and then
like eventually like you know got
together I was just like oh none of that
[__] [__] matters because she just
likes me for who I am you know so like I
don't have to like fake being like cool
or whatever because again like you know
I've only ever been with one person in
my life what's that that was hockey sir
was there worries about the online
aspect of it and and being a little bit
influencer was there ever conversations
about it a little bit Yeah I think like
it was kind of interesting to kind of
get to it was like meeting a completely
different person again yeah you know and
then falling in love with them again
like it was it was like I know your
online side of things and I really like
that side of things and then meeting
them IRL was kind of like it was this is
same same but different you know like it
was it was kind of like oh I see new
sides of you that I never got to see
during the whole online thing
um and so now I'm glad to know that like
not only do not only did I get to see
those sides of her but I actually like
those sides of her and it's and it kind
of like you know made me realize like oh
yeah I think this relationship is worth
pursuing that's sweet and now we've been
together for seven years
[Music]
I actually because I've never asked you
this yeah how was the conversation about
uh deciding to go public with it what
was the conversation
you were not you it wasn't enough
it just felt like after I mean from my
perspective it was like we knew you were
dating and then suddenly it was just
public knowledge and everyone knew yeah
and I don't remember was there an
announcement video how did it all yeah
there was an announcement video how was
that like how did that all come around
so who brought it up originally we
decided that like okay for the first
maybe three or four months we would kind
of keep it private when did you decide
this was that like when we started going
out is online yeah so like who brought
this idea up uh I think Archie did okay
yeah so Aki was like Hey I want to like
make sure this is like you know legit
and we actually like like each other's
company regardless of the whole YouTube
thing
so let's like kind of keep it as private
as possible for the first maybe like
three or four months
um and I was like sure that makes sense
so you know I could like spend time with
her off camera you know actually like
Bond a proper relationship with her
right like regardless of the YouTube
videos and then obviously when she came
to visit me in Japan and when I would go
visit her in Vegas we would make videos
together and then it started to get and
less inconspicuous of like they might be
dating yeah
um and so I think the breaking point for
me especially was like the point where
it was like the worst kept secret of
like okay these guys are clearly like
together or you know at least in a very
intimate relationship together so I said
to Aki I was like hey it's been like you
know three or four months since we've
been together now
what do you think about going public
um and she was like At first she was
kind of like oh you know I want to give
it a little bit more time but I also
understand that like at this point we
might as well just get it out of the way
so that we can just do whatever the [__]
we want so then we were like all right
cool so we went public we we each
uploaded a video I decided to do the
videos so my video was the announcement
video of saying like we're dating and
then Aki's video on her channel was the
video breaking down how it happened
we are [__] milking this
if we're coming now we're not doing
this yeah yeah we are doing a two-parter
now the question is who's going to be
part one yeah is it me or you how was
the reaction initially to it because I I
get um any of this I remember I remember
it happening but I don't remember any of
the reactions I think it was pretty I
mean this is weird for me to say
personally but like I think it was like
pretty big especially in the attitude
Community because yeah it was kind of
the first time where two Anna tubers who
you know were fairly well known at the
time especially in the community kind of
decided to get together yeah
um like I other than Sydney and gone I
don't really know anything you guys came
into it no I mean like we won uh I mean
Sydney wasn't really making content we
were right so yeah I mean I think
everyone knows Sydney yeah if they're
actually online presence has always been
yeah Sydney and also gone yeah yeah yeah
and it's like I was at the time I you
know there was a long time where I
wasn't doing YouTube full time I did
YouTube full-time like three years after
no maybe less cycle yeah I think I think
the time time that I think the time that
we announced our relationship publicly
God was stolen his hiatus
yeah I think so I believe bro like uh
the reason when you announce it that's
the reason we became friends yeah I I
remember this vividly because I remember
we were alone with this yeah this wasn't
in the lore of episode one oh no it's
like like it's the fact okay here's his
here's what I remember uh because I
think this was about the time when I was
like coming back to YouTube actually
because I remember being in Thailand
yeah uh and I remember like coming back
from this ax trip being like Jerry's uh
you know uh like he hates me
like Joey hates me I hate him we're just
not gonna get along that comes after
dating hockey you hear the story about
long-distance relationship and I don't
know why you're just like oh he's a
human now
like oh we're Bros I get I get what he's
going through
he just like me for real I send Jerry a
message being like yo congratulations
man I get it in long distance
relationship and Joey replied and I'm
that tweet well
what that made me realize oh maybe uh
maybe maybe be maybe Joey's a real one
maybe we'll get along yeah you think
you're going to hate the most turn out
to be the best friend no it was really
surprising because I remember when we
went public we got I I at least I got a
lot of like private DMS from like other
Anna tubers uh and messages from other
Anna tubers who I thought didn't know
who the [__] I was or cared who the [__]
I was but I feel that day it was so big
even comparatively to the scene it was
they all they all knew I guess so yeah
because like I had all these like you
know that's how I became close with guys
like chibi reviews because like I didn't
even know he knew who I was and they
sent me a DM being like yo congrats on
you being with Aki like that's [__]
cool and I'm like oh [__] I didn't even
know you knew who I was so it kind of
like weirdly validated me in that
community in the same way because I
always thought I was kind of like the
anomaly that just like popped up out of
nowhere and I thought like like gaunt
initially had I just thought everyone
[__] hated me right so I never like
really even tried to interact with the
attitude community at that point but
then when I came out with Aki I was like
I realized I was like oh people in the
community actually one know who I am and
two actually care about who I am yeah
yeah and so that's that was kind of my
window to be like hey let me try and hit
up these other you know creators in the
energy community and you know some of
them like gone and you know like some
other people I'm I'm still I still talk
to pretty regularly and I'm pretty close
with and we're in good terms and stuff
like that so I think all in all it was a
good decision to do
um it's interesting how it's changed
though like nowadays people don't make
those videos anymore
please please guys but also people just
don't make videos about being like I'm
in a relationship no no I think it's
creators have I mean not to say it
wasn't a good idea but I think it's the
maturity levels of YouTubers have kind
of gone a bit better now I think so I
think the whole talking about that stuff
is kind of like yeah